manuel valls considère qu'il a le
monopole de l'intérêt de la france du
mot responsabilité
en réalité il se comporte comme
quelqu'un dans cette affaire c'est le
remporter et de réunifier bonsoir a tous
invités de préparatoire à cette semaine
thierry mandon secrétaire d'état à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche
bonsoir soi et merci d'être avec nous
pour répondre à trois grandes questions
cette semaine encore d'abord voulez-vous
désarmer le gouvernement en prenant la
fin du 49-3 qui est assez paradoxal le
jour où manuel valls ya recours pour
faire adopter la loi travaille ensuite
question toujours à l'iconoclaste que
vous êtes ou à l'avant gardiste thierry
mandon puisque vous aviez réclamé ici
même dès novembre 2014
une primaire pour françois hollande est
ce que vous avez eu raison trop tôt vous
répondrez à stéphanie le rouge de l'
agence france-presse
le partenaire de notre émission enfin
troisième question avec michael les à
metz de public sénat faut-il autoriser
la sélection à l'entrée en fac et sortir
en fait de l' hypocrisie puisque
libération a dévoilé ce matin les
curieux critères caché dans le logiciel
pour l'admission post bac
manuel valls donc à déclencher une
deuxième fois larmes constitutionnelle
du 49-3 pour faire adopter la loi
travail et la concertation est allé au
bout a plaidé le premier ministre qui a
fait son annonce tout à l'heure face à
la bronca de la droite dans l'hémicycle
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés en application de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
notre constitution
et la règle que le peuple français s'est
donné à lui-même
j'ai donc décidé après la délibération
du conseil des ministres du 10 mai
d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur le vote en nouvelle
lecture du projet de loi relatif au
travail alors thierry mandon est-ce que
vous approuvez le premier ministre quand
il dit prendre ses responsabilités
forcément je suis membre de son
gouvernement
ce n'est pas à la deuxième fois c'est là
c'était la deuxième occasion mais ça
avait déjà été fait et c'est pour mettre
fin à un débat qui n'a que trop duré
mais pourtant on est bien d'accord vous
levez coeur et dans l'express cette
semaine le 49-3 vous voulez le voir
disparaître
oui mais vous pouvez pas mélanger une un
cadre institutionnel qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui et la nécessité de réfléchir
à moyen terme sous fasse arrêter de
penser je pense qu'il ya un sujet
démocratique dans le pays dans le 49 3
dès qu'un des épiphénomènes qui met une
réflexion globale et qui devra le moment
venu être à gorée dans la bannière envie
de savoir pourquoi vous voulez supprimer
49 3 mais c'est quoi c'est un aveu
d'impuissance non en l'espèce si vous
m'amenez à la halle explications
conjoncturelles c'est d'une certaine
manière le constat d'échec malgré un
certain nombre de propositions de
compromis d'avancé y compris par rapport
à la première lecture l'assemblée
nationale est enfermé dans des postures
qui traduisent l'état d'une ce débat
démocratique aujourd'hui qu'il faut
sortir de cela ça a quand même beaucoup
trop duré d'accord pas parce que vous
dites qu'il faut supprimer le 49-3 si je
ne me trompe pas parce que ça oblige à
trouver un compromis donc c'est bien un
échec ça vient aujourd'hui la cité de
trouver un compromis sur cette fameuse
loi travail les 49 3 est toujours un
constat d'échec
si j'ai le premier ministre le dit
lui-même à la tribune de l'assemblée et
d'un puits silat et d'impuissance
politique pas la puissance puisque
justement celle inverse c'est justement
l'occasion de trancher un débat qui n'a
que trop duré cc c'est l'échec de
discussions d'avancé que le gouvernement
a fait qu'ils n'ont pas permis d'aboutir
à quoi vous essayez également j'imagine
que le gouvernement a fait suffisamment
d'efforts vers le compromis
le crois je crois que je crois que ce
texte est devenu a une portée désormais
dans le débat politique symbolique quand
on regarde sa réalité notamment ce qui
pose problème son article 2 il n'est pas
vrai de décrire cet article comme une
menace contre les droits des
travailleurs
je pense même qu'il ya des garanties
notamment sur ce qu'on appelle l'accord
majoritaire
c'est à dire le fait que pour qu'un
accord soit signé désormais il faudra au
moins 50% des salariés contre 30%
aujourd'hui qu'on a une qui a des
garanties apportées par ci alors
commencer c'est devenu symbolique c'est
un remake mais quand même on entend les
arguments même si on n'est pas forcément
d'accord vous entendez benoît hamon qui
est dit mais non l'article 2 c'est
synonyme de talking social c'est ce que
disent aussi une grande partie des
syndicats contestataires bien sûr je
mets de côté là c'est l'opinion sont
divisés et derrière cette division il ya
finalement la culture politique de
l'affrontement entre ceux qui
considèrent que désaccord entre des
parties sur le terrain permettent du
progrès social de 4,9 permet du progrès
social et ceux qui pensent que la
garantie c'est d'abord la loi c'est
d'abord le vote mais dans l'économie
d'aujourd'hui
objectivement avec la diversité des
entreprises je pense qu'il faut la
fluidité que permettent les accords
d'entreprise alors si on se projette à
parce que vous estimez que
supprimer le 49 3 et est fondée est ce
que vous ne craignez pas de désarmer les
gouvernements futurs mais si vous voulez
m'inviter à une réflexion globale
oui mais on peut sur une ruse et la
refondation démocratique soit réflexion
absolument passionnante
il ya en effet un certain nombre de
sujets qui méritent d'être reposée à
commencer par la façon dont on fabrique
la loi les pouvoirs respectifs du
parlement et de l'exécutif et la façon
de préparer les textes avant que de les
voter les concertation obligatoire les
garanties l'autorité indépendante et
donc d'entendre ça mais le débat sans
réussite de votre réflexion de
glaciologie quand même vous êtes
ministre du gouvernement et hop vous
arriver le jour pour le premier ministre
utilise de 49 wabo dit il faudra le
supprimer un jour bien sûr mais je vous
dis suis pas en train de dire autre
chose je vous dis que dans une
architecture de fabrique de la loi
repenser j'ai d'ailleurs fait un rapport
préparé un rapport parlementaire que
j'ai pas pu terminer puisque j'ai été
nommé au gouvernement qu ont terminé de
manière remarquable
régis juanico dé laure de la raudière et
que dans une fabrique différente de la
loire repenser à l'image de ce qui se
fait dans les pays internationaux
il doit on doit pouvoir se passer donc
de dispositifs entre mille a changé les
choses dans le pays arrive et une
culture de compromis on en est loin
c'est pour le reste moi pas du fantasme
c'est des choses qui se font déjà qu'ils
ont été mises en oeuvre depuis dix ans
dans un certain nombre de pays étrangers
en europe
je pense que la france a une session de
2,2 de rattrapage à faire sur des outils
de bonne gouvernance à côté desquels on
n'est pas créée depuis dix ans vous
pensez que depuis 4 2 puis 10 on
réfléchit long quatre ans on se projette
j'aimerais vous pensez que manuel valls
pourrait être un premier ministre
149 60 sans possibilité de recours il
pourrait je pense que l'on la cus et
d'affaires l'accusent d'avoir voulu
d'abord montrer ses muscles non mais ça
c'est de la polémique politico fois ça
existe dans la dans la vie politique
enfin moi je me rappelle d'une chose
c'est le premier discours d'investiture
de manuel valls déclaration de politique
générale à l'assemblée nationale où il a
posé directement la question
démocratique et j'ai une conviction
profonde c'est qu'il n'est pas satisfait
de la situation d'aujourd'hui de l'état
du débat démocratique dans le pays
2-2 finalement du fait qu' on n'est plus
dans des affrontements dans des postures
dans des petites choses que dans des
grands débats de lille ne pas satisfaire
je suis convaincu qu'il n'est pas
satisfait de rien ne manque pas une
occasion de lire d'appeler jean la
responsabilité d'accord la quiétude
correct à l'assemblée france a pas trop
voulu vous l'arbitré la semaine
prochaine ou dans quinze jours ils vous
il vous répondra mais en tout cas cette
question démocratique
la satisfaction que produit aujourd'hui
l'état du demo débat démocratique dans
le pays et la nécessité de leur pensée
ça je suis persuadé que lui comme le
président la république sont convaincus
de sa valeur aujourd'hui la faute
incombe à manuel valls il en écoute bien
sûr les frondeurs je vous propose
d'écouter laurent baumel qui est très
dur envers le premier ministre le
diviseur manuel valls considère qu'il a
le monopole de l'intérêt de la france du
mot responsabilité en réalité se
comporte comme quelqu'un dans cette
affaire qui avait la possibilité de
réunifier un minimum sa famille
politique de d'avoir une sortie par le
haut avec nous mais aussi avec peut-être
les syndicats et qui cultive au nom du
fait qu'il cultive sa propre image
d'autorité d'intransigeance sa propre
construction politique finalement et
médiatique est en train de bavarder de
bousiller les possibilités de sortir de
cette affaire de la loi travail par le
savez le 49-3 ça va être vécu très
douloureusement par beaucoup de gens
c'est une nouvelle fois un acte de
brutalité alors il ya du vrai dans ce
que dit laurent baumel
d'abord c'est pas bien de s'en prendre à
la personne du premier ministre comme il
le fait j'ai rompu en baptisant style sa
méthode oui non mal à personne nous faut
c'est une critique politique mais
personnel du style de la méthode de la
façon d'être présumés de laurent baumel
c'est pas bien ce surtout que je crois
que laurent baumel comme d'autres et
c'est tout à fait
respectables sont des frondeurs du
premier jour moi j'ai connu laurent
baumel à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
siégé avec lui avant même que manuel
valls se soit premier ministre il était
frondeur
c'est tout à fait son droit il a droit
d'être en désaccord avec l'orientation
politique du gouvernement mais c'est pas
la personnalité de manuel valls qui est
en cause c'est une certaine lecture un
certain nombre de convictions que
laurent baumel à adé quelques-uns de ses
amis de désaccords sur la ligne
politique du gouvernement et c'est là
dessus qu'il faut se placer ça sert à
rien d'essayer d'enfoncer la personne du
ministre la socialiste karine berger
estime que le premier ministre devrait
démissionner faute de majorité
ben pourquoi démissionner faute de
majorité il va le texte va probablement
être adoptée il ya des règles
institutionnelles
là aussi on peut en penser ce qu'on veut
mais tant qu'elle existe en l'état on
les respecte parce que s'il n'y a pas de
république
l'art etc ca docteur montre 49 jouera
aussi une 106 les urnes à la fin que
motion de censure s'il ya une motion de
censure votée par l'assemblée
ça veut dire en escapade majorité ya
plus de majorité et qui a pas de
majorité alternative et s'il n'y avait
pas au dessin bien qu'une majorité donc
comment est ce que vous avez fait quand
vous entendez certains de vos amis du
parti socialiste se dire prêts à voter
une motion de censure que qui appelle
d'ailleurs le parti communiste français
mangent pas envie de passer du plein
d'énergie que ce qu'on passe déjà qui
est démesuré à régler des histoires
entre les rebelles et les forces qui
composent de la majorité lors de la
défaite non plus balai comme ça
malheureusement
moi je dis ce que je pense écoutez par
exemple jean claude mailly le patron de
fo il promet déjà d'autres rendez vous
avec les autres syndicats contestataires
qui veulent continuer à mobiliser même
si aujourd'hui vous l'avez vu leur
défilé était quand même moins peuplées
en écoute en tous les cas jean claude
mailly on n'est pas satisfait de ce
projet de loi on al face à un
gouvernement qui a accepté de bouger un
petit peu sur un point mais sur le fond
du dossier
c'est d'une rigidité que je n'ai jamais
connu donc à la fois du gouvernement
mais aussi implicitement du président de
la république on a contenu d'autres
premiers ministres égide avec des
brillants un public plus souple donc à
partir de ce moment là s'ils
maintiennent mordicus ce qu'ils veulent
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on lève le
pied
on va discuter des modalités avec les
autorisations mais rendez vous à la
rentrée ce sera le chewing gum qui va
leur coller aux pompes pendant un bon
bout de temps avec jardin alors le
chewing gum va vous coller aux pompes
pendant un bon bout de temps encore vous
voyez que vous voyez quand même que
l'état du débat démocratique
quand entre des forces politiques et des
forces syndicales respectable comme les
faux on en est à utiliser ce genre de
métaphores ça veut dire qu'on doit
pouvoir être meilleur pour repenser et
refonder le débat démocratique dans le
pays
encore une fois les divisions ça allait
les disparités les convictions
différentes les désaccords ça existe
mais une démocratie ça fonctionne pas
sans respect mutuel et de ce point de
vue là je pense qu'il ya des progrès à
faire et est donc il est nécessaire de
repenser un peu tout ça mais comment va
la démocratie quand on voit un climat
social aussi pesant et qui va perdurer
d'après les syndicats vous l'avez
entendu ça vous inquiète
oui mais ça m'inquiète pour
des raisons d'actualité et politiques et
sociales parce que avec les risques
auxquels le pays est confronté à une
situation économique qui reste
incertaine même si elle s'améliore du
fait notamment des incertitudes liées
aux briques site
on aurait besoin d'un peu plus de calme
et de stabilité puis ça m'inquiète
surtout pour des raisons de fond ce que
je pense que cet accident c'est cette
dégradation du débat démocratique
finalement elle n'est pas sans raisons
de fond je pense qu'il ya des mutations
profondes dans la société qui sont en
train de se dérouler sans même qu'on y
prête attention
l'élévation du niveau de qualité globale
le rôle du numérique qui fait que les
citoyens sont à la fois plus puissant
individuellement et au moment où les
grandes organisations sont tétanisés
grave le niveau de menace non ça change
les paramètres jugeant la démarche et en
profondeur et donc les règles actuelles
de l' architecture politique de la façon
de prendre des décisions publiques si
elle n'évolue pas ça grince et il ya des
accidents en estrie est d'accord c'est
la raison que vous prenez un sergent de
mesures pour ça je pense fusionnelle je
pense vraiment que aujourd'hui la
machine a décidé doit être pensé à
l'aune des évolutions profondes de la
société là et que si ça se passe pas
bien c'est pas seulement parce que tel
acteur et comme si et tel accueil comme
ça c'est parce qu'elles aient raison
plus profonde de retard de l'adaptation
de nos machines démocratique c'est pour
ça que je plaide dans le papier dont
vous avez parlé alors vous avez bien sûr
rendu hommage à michel rocard ces
derniers jours thierry mandon vous savez
combien de fois il a utilisé le 49-3 lui
pas moins de 28 fois oui alors c'est une
situation tout à fait particulière je
suis pas là pour les exonérer oui mais
c'était une situation de majorité dite
relative stèle qui avait pas il ne
disposait pas l'assemblée nationale de
majorité absolue
pour avoir cette majorité normand il
était fier il partait de matignon avec
une cote supérieure à 50% voilà comme
quoi personne ne lui a été créé de cette
façon de gouverner qui date quand même
des années de la fin des années 80 pour
mémoire c'était quand même il ya
presque trente ans alors je vous propose
d'écouter michel rocard qui évoquait le
17 mai tout à fait récemment
l'incompréhension des français en
matière économique
autre caractéristique française si le
dernier des pays d'europe où on
n'apprend pas l'économie ni à l'école ni
au collège ni au lycée on n'apprend pas
comment voulez vous que dans un appareil
environnement avec des syndicats si
faible en plus la structure de syndicats
maintenant c'est qu'elle se sert au
complet tout à fait vivre privé et
qu'ils restent puissantes dans le
secteur public et le secteur public
auront négocié pas d'économie on regarde
pas les grands équilibres au monde y est
que le 10 du budget qui fait ce qu'il
peut dans ces grands équilibres à lui
tout ça était chiant mais tout ça est
profondément culturelle alors dû aussi
sauver toujours donc rien n'a changé
selon michel rocard
oui évidemment ça m'apporte des français
mais là je suis un poignant moi je pense
que je vais pas tout à fait d'accord
avec lui je pense qu'il ya une évolution
majeure qui quand même explique beaucoup
des difficultés des temps actuels c'est
que les français dans les générations
dans la jeune génération aujourd'hui
dans les moins de 30 ans sont diplômés
de l'enseignement supérieur et 44%
d'entre eux un taux considérable quand
il ya deux générations il est diplômé à
20% une élévation du très puissante du
niveau de qualification des français tu
niveau d'intelligence des français qui
est une des progressions les plus fortes
au monde
j'ai comparé il ya des études de
cellules très précises et que cette
intelligence individuelles comparées à
la force que donne ajouté pardon à
l'argent ce que donne le numérique fait
que les français comprennent bien mieux
les enjeux que ce qu'on pense et croire
que les enjeux comprennent que les
français comprennent pas les enjeux
économiques de mon point de vue c'est
faux il les comprend très bien
ils ont des convictions ils ont une
culture profonde ya presque une
anthropologie dans la société du rapport
à la protection collective du rapport au
droit qui est une spécificité française
mais il est faux de dire qu'ils
comprennent pas les enjeux je pense
exactement l inverse
voilà c'est bien parce que c'est
courageux
se distinguer les propos de michel
rocard mais on n'est rien ne serait pas
sur tous nos gars sur qui et son
héritier aujourd'hui je crois qu'il n'y
en a pas il n'attend que jour
malheureusement c'est une de ses
dernières paroles qui était très
puissante tête un interview qu'il a
donné un grand hebdomadaire et où
finalement ce qui apparaissait c'est
qu'ils ne se trouvaient pas sur la scène
politique actuelle en tout cas à gauche
d'eric alors on a beaucoup parlé du 40e
forum et vous prenez d'autres réformes
constitutionnelles âgées noté thierry
mandon donc sur le non cumul des mandats
dans le temps et puis également pour un
peu de proportionnelle on ira
quel est l'avenir de vos propositions la
deuxième partie de preuves par 3
maintenant avec stéphanie le rouge de l'
agence france-presse avez vous eu raison
trop tôt en réclamant ici même
c'était en novembre 2014 une primaire de
la gauche pour vous ne l'aviez expliqué
à relégitimer françois hollande
une primaire est indispensable
disiez-vous avant d'être démentie on
s'en souvient mais n'est ce pas trop
tard maintenant
écoutons d'abord marie noëlle lienemann
qui se déclare candidate
je pense qu'aujourd'hui une majorité
d'un peuple de gauche pour sanctionner
la ligne politique de françois hollande
et manuel valls
on le voit encore avec l'obligation de
passer par le 49-3 aujourd'hui et de
fait ces primaires doivent permettre
justement de montrer qu'une alternative
existe qu'elle peut rassembler dans la
diversité
un champ large mais un chant qui reprend
appui sur les valeurs de gauche je ne
renonce pas à ce que ces primaires
soient cette occasion là je pense que
tout est fait aujourd'hui pour
discréditer l'idée que ces primaires
soient ouvertes en essayant d'en faire
simplement un référendum propres aux
comptes gouvernement une somme à non et
nous sommes un certain nombre un peu
dans toutes les composantes de la gauche
à penser qu'on peut mobiliser les
français pour faire de cette primaire ce
qui était jadis un peu le premier tour
mais qui maintenant avec le poids du
front national elle risque d'être absent
deuxième tour mérite de passer par cette
case primaire
voilà pour marie noëlle lienemann
bonsoir stéphane lerouge à vos questions
à notre invité sur cette fameuse
primaire bonsoir monsieur le ministre
donc vous avez été un précurseur cette
affaire de primaire est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de la manière dont ça s'engage
est ce que vous pensez comme semblent le
dire madame lienemann que ce sont
peut-être des primaires sur mesure pour
françois hollande
non je suis satisfait qu'elle ait lieu
voilà qu'elle était décidée après pas
sûr que les françaises et les français
vont passer des nuits entières à
s'interroger sur le détail de la
primaire sont intéressants mais voilà
elle devait avoir lieu c'est pareil dans
une réflexion souvent moins de succès
que les primaires de jeunes ans et je
n'en sais strictement rien je pense en
revanche que il ya une querelle de
famille à gauche depuis le début du
quinquennat d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière c'est traditionnel à gauche et
quand il ya une querelle de famille
c'est bien convoquer le conseil de
famille pour la règle et voilà c'est ce
que finalement c'est sale et les
primaires et c'est une bonne chose que
ça se règle comme ce serait ce que ça
peut être des primaires loyale sur les
thèmes qu'elles le seront forcément
utilisé par arnaud montebourg de
dédougou
voilà que pour que ce soit loyal il faut
dix mille bureaux de vote un système de
parrainage qui fasse un filtre assez
clair voilà donc il veut les conditions
de la primaire de 2011 est ce que vous
le rejoignez dans cette demande écoutez
moi je suis pas ni greffier ni notaires
donc je vais pas compter le nombre de
bureaux de vote et mais il faut qu'elle
soit loyale mais comment peut-on
imaginer une seconde que ceux qui
décident de cette primaire décide en
même temps de la truck et voit cet
absurde
c'était us et tout ça se passe
publiquement il ya des des médias il ya
des millions de deux hommes et femmes de
gauche qui attendent ses prix mais en a
il ya pas de risque il ya aucun risque
il ya simplement un principe que tout le
monde doit accepter en participant à la
primaire c'est que le gagnant a gagné
non le gagnant a gagné ça c'est très
important parce que sinon ça veut dire
qu'on a plus rien à faire ensemble
donc il faut accepter sans aucune
réserve s'il a des exigences sur le
nombre de buts de deux bureaux de vote
très bien il faut accepter cette règle
tout bête que le candidat désigné par la
primaire est le candidat de tous ceux
qui y ont participé
c'est le seul cadre politique et ça
c'est évidemment c'est à chacun de faire
cet effort et le la primaire semble un
aveu de faiblesse pour françois hollande
donc voilà évidemment tout le monde
soupçonne mais pourquoi manoeuvre en
fait voilà qui serait pas totalement
honnête donc on peut comprendre que les
gens aient des doutes sinon c'est pas la
wii
non mais la loyauté c'est très
intéressant ce débat de la primaire
parce que derrière il ya une certaine
conception de la présidence de la
république on dit en gros ceux qui
s'opposent à la primaire 10 m'écouter le
président de la république au mans mais
allez voir le peuple à aller voir les
citoyens les voir ceux et celles de sa
famille politique pour leur demander
s'il peut se représenter
voilà on raisonne comme si le présent à
publique françois hollande aujourd'hui
hier d'autres demandes août étaient des
sortes d'hommes providentiels qui avait
par eux mêmes une légitimité qui faisait
que naturellement devait se représenter
moi je pense que c'est pas la bonne
vision de ce qu'est le président de la
république dans la société d'aujourd'hui
et je pense d'ailleurs que françois
hollande à cette vision la selle à
présent appuyé que c'est un premier de
cordée
c'est quelqu'un qui emmène une corde et
ceux et celles qui partagent ces
convictions
ça peut pas être monolithiques par free
y aura des désaccords qui les emmènent
qui les dirige pendant cinq ans sur un
parcours qui prend la responsabilité de
l'équipage qui indique la voie qui
parfois motive les gens qui parfois les
engueuler quand il faut les engrais et
c'est cette vision là de ce qu'est un
président de la république de ce que
doit être un président de la république
moderne qui je crois est amorcée dans
dans ce quinquennat elle implique
justement cette légitimation par sa
famille parce que pour être premier de
cordée ou font une corde et voilà et qui
a d'autres dans la cordée que ce parti
cndd qui participeront de désigner notre
candidat du coup le candidat quand il
est candidat
vous savez vous s'il va se présenter
présent la plupart des déclarations très
simple il a dit moi je serai
candidat si j'arrive à faire baisser le
chômage en fin d'année donc on attend la
fin de l'année à là où je suis dans le
gouvernement
modestement j'essaye pour ma part de
contribuer à cet objectif la démoniste
qui sont bien plus explosif mois au
travail à l'économie aux finances et
puis on espère que ça chômage baissera
que prison pour être candidat mais pour
l'instant nul n'en sait rien alors il ya
déjà beaucoup de tiraillements avec par
exemple la vie ce matin même de jean
michel baylet qui est votre mini né
votre collègue au gouvernement ben ali
ministre de l'aménagement du territoire
il estime lui que le pacte fondateur est
rompue donc avec son parti le parti
radical de gauche écouter son porte-
drapeaux au sénat jacques mézard le
président du groupe et rds ça je crois
que ce serait une erreur d'être candidat
à des primaires organisées de telle
manière
quant au sein de la belle-alliance le
parti socialiste décide d'organiser
primaire sans avertir les seuls alliés
qui lui reste c'est quand même une drôle
de manière de faire de la politique
encore une fois c'est une manoeuvre
politicienne et je crois que les
français en ont plus qu'assez de ce type
de comportement ce qu'ils veulent c'est
des actes et des discours qu'ils soient
en harmonie avec les acteurs alors vous
êtes vous avez entendu une manoeuvre
politicienne du le président du groupe
rdse du sénat
y'a pas de primaire ont dit ah il décide
tout seuls dans leur coin il nous met
devant le fait accompli
il ya des primaires on dit c'est une
manoeuvre politicienne je pense qu'il
faut sortir de ça si telle ou telle
formation politique de la majorité envie
de présenter un candidat qu'elle le
fasse
et si elle a des exigences sur les
conditions d'organisation qu'elle les
expriment et j'imagine je n'imagine pas
une seconde que ces propositions
seraient pas entendus parce qu'encore
une fois ceux qui organisent les
primaires ont intérêt à ce qu'elle soit
réussie
vous pensez en fait que le prg
une espèce de chantage pur jeu pour
finir les conditions non je pense rien
je pense mais je pense que je sais pas
je ne sais pas ce qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent
enfin si j'écoute votre interview en
tout cas ils expriment une question sont
relatives aux conditions d'organisation
que les relations entre le ps et le prg
sont pas très bons en ce moment parce
qu'il y avait là la première assemblée
nationale de la belle alliance populaire
samedi et puis le prg avait fait savoir
dès mercredi qu'il n'en serait pas
qu'est ce qui se passe le ps est à ce
point décrié en ce moment qu'il ne
faille pas s'afficher à ses côtés
écoutez j'ai malheureusement pas
forcément loisir de suivre dans le
détail de la vie des partis politiques
et à commencer par celui auquel
j'appartiens mais en revanche je peux
attester d'une chose c'est qu'au
gouvernement il ya plusieurs ministres
du prj à monsieur baylet est dit que le
pacte fondateur héros non mais moi je
voulais voir fonctionner ou d'ailleurs
je travaille avec lui très étroitement
avec lui il n'y a pas de difficultés
dans la gestion gouvernementale s'il n'y
a pas de difficultés dans la gestion
gouvernementale ça veut dire qu'on est
dans le même bateau si on est dans le
même bateau il ya peut-être des petites
difficultés peut-être des petites
susceptibilités je ne vois pas que ces
problèmes là ne puisse pas être réglée
assez aisément
on a quand même l'impression qu'il ya de
moins en moins de monde dans le bateau
puisque cette belle alliance populaire
il y avait ni le prg ni les frondeurs
nier les aubrystes en finit manqué pas
mal de monde et le lendemain donc de 7
assemblée nationale jeu christophe conte
balises cambadélis a annoncé pardon que
il voulait reporter l'université d'été
du ps on a l'impression que vous ne
pouvez même plus vous réunir tous
ensemble
c'est une décision qui a dû être très
difficile pour jean christophe cornelie
pour l'ensemble du parti socialiste bon
je sais pas si c'était une bonne idée
d'aller à nantes 1-2 d'enlever la
l'université de la rochelle pour pour
aller à nantes
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que se
sont passées ces dernières semaines des
actes extrêmement graves contre des
centaines de parlementaires socialistes
des centaines ouais après au moins une
centaine en tout cas il y en a c'est
passé par unique boutique c'est pas
trois ou quatre dégradation de
permanence
alessio verbales répétées ccd fait c'est
l'effet est que le premier secrétaire
prennent un certain nombre de
précautions organise des forums
décentralisée plus qu'aux plus de
grandes universités à nantes c'est
probablement une solution de sagesse
c'est pas de gaîté de coeur
vous savez pour les militants
socialistes c'est pas rien à rochelle
maintenant d'université d'été c'est un
moment où on se retrouve à un moment où
fraternisent où on s'engueule aussi et
il ya parfois besoin de le faire ou on
se dit les choses et le fait de devoir
surseoir cette année à cet événement la
saluaient une décision très difficile à
prendre pour jean christophe cambadélis
mais malheureusement les choses étant ce
qu'elles sont les actes inqualifiables
commis contre un certain nombre de
parlementaires de responsables
socialistes étant ce qu'ils sont c'est
probablement la solution saignant on se
demande vraiment comment le parti
socialiste va pouvoir faire campagne par
exemple il ya eu une réunion hier soir à
lille 2 et où la gauche qui était
fortement chuté notamment par des
cégétistes et il y avait des forces de
police très impressionnante avec
stéphane le foll qui est obligé
d'arriver par une porte arrière comment
est ce que vous allez faire campagne
avec ces violences et ce risque
permanent mais on fera campagne de
verser dans l'ansé dans neuf mois d'ici
là un certain nombre de deux
l'amélioration de la situation
économique est probablement je l'espère
sur le front du chemin social montreuil
quand on a des résultats
et puis surtout il faut que chaque
acteur en responsabilité prennent que la
conscience de cette dégradation du débat
public qui après qu'une dégradation
sémantique on revient pas sur le passage
de tout à l'heure avec les responsables
mais mais sans respect sans respect ça
fonctionne pas la démocratie avec des
désaccords politiques ça fonctionne
c'est fait pour ça la démocratie c'est
un système de régulation des différences
politiques des arbitrages politiques des
compromis pour que ça fonctionne
non mais sans résister entation là quand
on vous écoute thierry mandon mais
l'apaisement il n'est pas pour demain on
le voit sur le bruit à travers vous
c'est vous qui faites qui lisait dans le
marc de café
moi je suis un j'écoutais modeste fait
je suis un modeste politique et ge a dit
cette chose toute simple c'est que sans
respect ça marche pas et c'est une
préoccupation que chaque acteur public
doit avoir à l'esprit si aujourd'hui les
fausses les forces contestatrice de la
démocratie à commencer par en france ont
le vent en poupe c'est parce que ceux
qui doivent apporter la démocratie par
leur comportement par leur façon dette
par leur façon d'organiser le débat
public sont pas à la hauteur elle avoue
viser là c'est tous les veaux viser la
gauche de la gauche souhaite klaus
nous avons tous moi même une
responsabilité de remettre de la qualité
et du respect dans le débat démocratique
parce que si on tire pas le débat vers
le haut y'a pas de raison que des
comportements absolument inadmissible ne
prospère est ce que la qualité du débat
ne concerne pas d'abord les ministres
entre eux on a assisté hier à une scène
étrange sur twitter avec ce qu'on dit
whitt clash vous avez vu un
les bisbilles avec christian eckert
soutenu d'ailleurs par manuel valls et
le rationnement où va-t-on avec vous le
voyez emmanuel macron épinglé par le
secrétaire d'état au budget emmanuel la
conca qualifié de 2,2 sur rome assas et
twitter ça leur sert à rien mais quand
pas twitter ce sont des ministres à vous
demander abonnés d'appeler à la paix
non mais c'est un média qui a une
audience à lundi aux deux médias non
mais je ne dis pas que le média est
responsable ce que je veux dire c'est
que twitter ça fait partie de ces
nouveaux outils numériques qui sont
finalement des outils à épanchements de
ses propres états d'âme voilà et là il a
été vexé et peut-être pour des bonnes
raisons puisqu'il est responsable des
douanes
donc il a écrit naturellement ce qu'il
ce qu'ils sentaient voilà et on peut
comprendre la réaction d'humeur de
christian eckert
combien j'ai une petite question vous
étiez vous avez soutenu arnaud
montebourg en 2011 et pour la primaire
du ps à cette époque qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ses premiers pas en fin de son
retour en politique il ya une grosse
incertitude politique avec
arnaud montebourg j'ai du mal à pour
l'instant mais probablement le clarifier
ses positions dans les semaines qui
viennent comprendre sa position sur une
question qui pour moi est majeur qui est
la question européenne
je me demande s'il n'est pas en train de
devenir souverainiste or je pense pour
ma part que l'europe a besoin d'être
paramétrer mais a vraiment besoin non
seulement d'exister mais reconsolider
par une façon un peu différente de la
faire fonctionner que ce qui a
fonctionné aujourd'hui dit c'est qu'il
faut mener un bras de fer avec l'europe
pour la reconstruire et enfin aider à sa
reconstruction
est-ce que c'est pas justement ce que
fait par exemple magna mais valls quand
il dit que de manière unilatérale il
pourrait ne pas appliquer la directive
sur les travailleurs détachés il n'y a
pas la france et l'europe il n'y a pas
la france d'un côté l'europe de l'autre
la france surtout avec le bre vite c'est
la deuxième économie européenne c'est au
coeur de l'europe voulait faire un bras
de fer avec qui avec vous même donc si
la france ne porte pas des projets de
construction renforcée de nouveaux
horizons pour des coopérations entre les
pays si plutôt que de faire un compte
un bras de fer et qu'on sait pas trop
qui elles portent pas une dimension
constructive la france il ya dans leurs
fichiers alors l'europe mais évidemment
le constat qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie
que les procédures politiques sont trop
longues à faire tout ça ça a été fait
refaire n'en est plus là c'est sert à
rien de le problème c'est qu'au moment
où frais pour que cette belle idée
quelle idée européenne
cannes a quand même pris un grand coup
dans l' aile comment on fait pour
qu'elle prenait ce qu'elle à la fois que
qu'elle redevienne ce qu'elle a été un
espoir pour des millions de de français
et d'européens et moi je pense que
l'énergie d'un responsable politique
aujourd'hui c'est pas de passer son
temps à taper sur septembre dans les
dons les absences et insuffisantes sont
visibles mais plutôt de redéfinir en
quoi on faire remarcher
cette machine qui est en passe alors
thierry mandon vous avez évoqué les
amabilités qu'on s'échange à gauche
à écouter
maintenant ce que dit nicolas sarkozy
lui qui crient haro sur françois
hollande notamment sur le thème de
l'autorité
nous voyons les conséquences
désastreuses du mensonge de 2012 la loi
est comme riz n'est pour rien les
français ont compris depuis longtemps
karine copie ça changerait rien
ce qui est intéressant c'est le mensonge
c'est le sentiment d'impuissance
c'est la perte d'autorité c'est le
désordre qui risquent de détourner
chaque jour davantage les français de la
politique car le problème et françois
hollande c'est qui peut pas se faire
davantage de mal à lui même
au niveau où il en est ça peut guère
aller beaucoup beaucoup plus bas mais
peut tous nous entraîner il peut tous
deux entraînés dans cette faillite qui
est la sienne
je répondrai à ce réquisitoire sans
appel
une partie des réponses renvoi ou
séquence précédente sur la nature du de
l'aube des oppositions politiques et les
attaques personnelles qui ne me semble
pas de bonnes natures mais mais mais la
question de l'autorité vous savez c'est
une question tout le monde doit se poser
si à nicolas sarkozy avait l'autorité
qu'il estime nécessaires en politique
trois bleus mans il y aurait moins de
candidats aux primaires de la droite
je lis dans cette floraison absolument
surréaliste de candidature une
contestation de sa propre autorité donc
avant de faire des diagnostics pour
autrui il faut savoir c'est appliquer à
soi même est un risque qui ne gâte pas
là la primaire de la gauche c'est ton
explication des candidats n'en sait rien
pour l'instant je n'ai pas le sentiment
que ce soit déjà deux candidats de la
tendance écologiste pro gouvernementales
oui on verra mais j'ai pas le sentiment
que c'est soit aussi riche et diversifié
que ce que la droite propose pour
l'instant ils sont 1 combien 11 12 13 12
c'est quand même abondant nicolas
sarkozy parle de mensonge de 2012 c'est
non mais je vois pas où est le mensonge
en 2012 je ne vois pas où est le
mensonge en 2012 by n'était pas dans le
pernambouc mensonges et les accuse ben
on entend beaucoup trahison à gauche
alors donc c'est un peu la même notion
très trahison moi j'ai repris les
propositions du président de la
république lors de la présidentielle j
reprises et il a la quasi totalité de
ces propositions ont été mises en oeuvre
donc ce qui est vrai il ya une chose qui
est vrai que des revenus dans la
séquence 2012 aujourd'hui c'est nous
avons trouvé des entreprises encore en
état économique et financier beaucoup
plus dégradé d'accord que ce que nous
pensions et nous avons dû faire un
effort plus important que nous nous
imaginions pour restaurer leur taux de
marge ce qui a été fait mais qu'ils
exprimaient la france de beaucoup de
ressources
c'est l'objectif de la loi travail non
non non c'est la compétitivité des
entreprises non là l'objectif de la loi
travail c'est de d'adapter les
régulations sociales des entreprises les
relations sociales dans les entreprises
à la situation économique des
différentes branches et la diversité des
branches merci stéphane et les
troisièmes parties de préparer on va
parler maintenant de vos dossiers au
gouvernement thierry mandon avec mickaël
zeze de public sénat faut-il autoriser
la sélection à l'entrée en fac la
question est relancée en permanence et
notamment ce jour de résultats du bac
avec les révélations de libération ce
matin sur le système apb d admission
post bac qui cache qui cacherait en fait
une sélection déguiser un logiciel
orienté et des tournées qui utilise donc
des critères pour port a envoyé
certaines certains étudiants quand
certaines filières et d'autres - le
sénateur guy dominique kennel des
républicains vous interpelle en tout cas
monsieur le ministre sur cette question
monsieur le ministre vous savez que
l'affectation post bac est plutôt
hermétique encore de nos jours et que ce
que nous souhaitons au niveau de notre
mission c'est tout simplement que vous
publiez les code-source les algorithmes
qui permettent aux jeunes de connaître
quels sont les critères de sélection au
niveau de l'entrée dans le monde
universitaire je crois que vous êtes
plutôt enclin à le faire alors n'hésitez
pas et ils le courage de le faire
voilà je pense que tout le monde vous en
sera reconnaissant notamment les jeunes
qui s'orientent vers le supérieur et qui
souvent sont plus désorientés
qu'orientés le sénateur a raison de
demander la publication des algorithmes
d'apb ça a été fait il a probablement eu
l'occasion de s'y pencher c'est pas
torride un cd algorithmes ans quant au
code source n'est pas faisable
le code source et des codes absolument
confidentielles
si je veux respecter la confidentialité
de chacun des situations de chacun des
étudiants
si on axé autour tout tout tout est
public donc ça il ya des dossiers il ya
des règles précises qui interdisent la
publication du code source pour
l'algorithme c'est fait et d'ailleurs
c'est parce que c'est fait qu'un certain
nombre de dents quêtes ou de pseudo
enquête parce qu'on peut revenir sur les
les les faits entre guillemets révélé ce
matin qu'ils sont vraiment des
révélations qui font pschitt peuvent
s'appuyer sur wii ça fait bien allons-y
quand même sélection la fac
oui l'épreuve oui on voulait pas de
sélection est normal tendu mais je vois
qu'il ya pas de section je ne dis pas
caché mais pour cacher du tour mais elle
est pas caché pour dire combien il ya de
filières sélectives à l'université 3%
les filières sélectives à l'université
pourquoi parce que vous avez des
filières qui sont bi ou tri vague c'est
quand même normal quand vous avez des
filières qui amène à la license by ou
trilingues que vous vérifiez avant
d'intégrer des étudiants qu'il parle un
minimum les deux ou trois langues qui
vont faire l'objet du parcours alors
quand vous faites je juge comme des
exemples quand vous avez très dans très
peu de cas une licence physique et
anglais parce que vous elle elle repose
sur des coopérations internet c'est
pareil vous vérifiez niveau donc c'est
ça dont on parle c'est des filières en
très peu de 3 8% de l'ensemble des
filières qui se représente est clair que
des publics particuliers
est ce que faire de la sélection à la
fac est ce que c'est un gros mot puisque
c'est un tabou écoutez moi je pense que
la vraie formulation sémantique c'est
d'être exigeants sur l'orientation
renforcée des étudiants après la fin des
futurs étudiants
après le bac je pense que il y avait un
petit peu plus clair chez deux oui je
vais être très clair
la boutique je vais être très clair vous
avez des bacs qui on est on sait très
précisément ne prépare pas forcément à
la réussite en première année de licence
vous avez d un certain type de bac
rentrons pas dans le détail c'est pas
très important où vous où
statistiquement vous avez 3 % de chances
de réussite à la naissance donc ça ben
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le tri où on leur
dit pas non pourquoi il ya 3 % et cette
fois rassuré les dommages sont les
interdire on explique et c'est tous les
projets d'orientation qui s'amorce là
qu'on a recommencé qu'on a commencé pour
la première année cette année qu'on va
renforcer les prochains on explique on
doit avoir au lycée au moment où un pli
apb quelqu'un qui vous dit c'est ce que
j'appelle l'orientation renforcée
franchement tu devrais pas faire cette
série 7
tu devrais pas l'air mathématiques alors
donc on appelle ça quoi appelez-moi
sélection géré non de l'orientation de
sélection vous dit pas non par principe
parce que vous c'est bien mais c'est pas
bien vous sait pas quand ça se déclenche
un enfant vous savez pas quand ça se
déclenche un étudiant il ya des cas très
variées vous avez des gens qui d'un seul
coup en premier ne deviennent les très
bons élèves
et puis d'autres c'est en deuxième année
de licence donc vous savez pas mais vous
devez en revanche faire beaucoup plus
d'efforts pour orienter dans des
filières où ils ont des chances de
réussite des élèves qui ont accouru faut
qu'il faut clair pour tout le monde
pourquoi pour le dit pas tout simplement
ben c'est ce que j'ai en train de faire
oui mais d'accord mais voilà quand on
met ça c'est là une enquête qui est
faite par libération et d'autres et
d'autres subissent mail enquête
l'enquète qui est fait mais c'est assez
passionnant on découvrait tas de choses
mais ccb tant mieux si elle vous a
intéressé
oui on parle de 3 4% ddd des filières
sur des noms comme très significatif
d'étudiants un million cinq et étudiants
qu'on est seul aux mines le sénateur
en appeler à votre courage qui
arriverait si vous avez mémorable mais
moi le courage regard de rire que
l'université n'est pas forcément en fait
toutes les filières ne sont pas
forcément accessibles à tous
ce qu'elle principe aujourd'hui
dynamique de notre pays a tant aimé vous
dites ça pardon je voudrais pas faire ma
propre promotion je déteste ça mais ça
fait 14 ans je prends un exemple ça fait
14 ans qu'existe dans notre pays
de là ddd des règles de sélection caché
entre le master 1 et master de 14 ans il
rêvait lui cacher elle était cachée
jamais vu de couverture de libération ou
quelques autres journaux sur ce sujet là
ça fait 14 ans voilà qu'est ce qu'on a
fait pour la première fois il ya
quelques semaines on a publié au journal
officiel
l'ensemble des 1200 master 2 qui
désormais pourront faire de la sélection
savourons sélectionneur donc j'ai pas
peur de la sélection j'ai le courage de
le faire ça ne pose aucune difficulté
simplement je pense que l'enjeu pour le
pays aujourd'hui c'est pas de
sélectionner à l'entrée à l'université
c'est c'est de faire de l'orientation
pour que les gens réussissent mais c'est
au contraire donne d'avoir une vision ou
ceux qui accèdent à l'enseignement
supérieur sur le plus nombreux possible
le plus nombreux possible avec des gens
avec de vraies chances de réussite avec
des vraies chances de réussite du
orientation en mettant des moyens dans
le système parce que il nous manque
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle on se bat beaucoup sur les
questions budgétaires
et deuxième chose qu'il faut faire c'est
exiger de la qualité des diplômes
ça ça doit se payer donc master 2 je
voulais dit doctorat on vient de finir
une réforme doctorale c'est pareil ça
attendu depuis des années on fabrique le
système admission repose ainsi qu'on
appelle à la grève et il faut le
réformer
et on le fait chaque année cette année
où c'est ce qu'on a fait d'abord il ya
des chiffres que je vous donnais là
aujourd'hui qui sont des chiffres
nouveau il ya on a fait une réforme
d'apb l'année dernière on a fait trois
choses premièrement on publie de manière
spontanée
on appelle ça les pop up ça vient à
votre entre guillemets à votre visage
quand vous remplissez apb on publie les
chances de réussite que vous avez en
fonction de votre type de bail de
stocker de la filière voilà et les
salaires le temps que vous mettez pour
trouver un travail à la
à la fin de ses filles à la résultats de
la manoeuvre en france il y avait
l'année dernière
189 filière en tension il est 189 bière
partout en france où on pouvait plus
accepter des étudiants parce qu'il avait
trop de demandes cette année grâce à ses
efforts puis à d'autres on est à 78 donc
on a diminué de 60% les problèmes de
capacité d'accueil pardon en france par
un travail d'orientation appuyé et
d'information suivants allez on sait qui
est encore dire je m'habille encore du
chemin à parcourir
alors oui au mieux un autre sujet
beaucoup mais qui télescope avec c'est
ce débat sur la sélection dans
l'actualité ce sont les meilleurs
bacheliers
z'avez vu ça évidemment les meilleurs
bacheliers qui sont cons été privés
d'accès réservé à certaines filières
c'est pourtant c'était une mesure du
gouvernement présenté dans sa loi
et toi y ait égalité citoyenneté qui a
été rejeté par certains députés de la
gauche je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction indignée de barthélémy jaubert
qui est le président de l'université
paris sorbonne et je suis scandalisée de
voir que l'assemblée nationale a enlevé
cette possibilité de donner aux
étudiants ayant obtenu la mention enfin
aux lycéens ayant obtenu la mention très
très bien au baccalauréat une
possibilité d'accès privilégié dans les
filières dites intentions c'est-à-dire
les finir vous justement il ya trop
d'enfants pour pas suffisamment de place
c'est un signal désastreux qui est
envoyé aux futurs étudiants parce que
que peut-on à ce moment-là utilisé comme
critère de choix rien d'autre que le
tirage au sort dont on nous dit par
ailleurs qu'il est illégal
il y avait les contradictions dont il
faut nous collectivement de nous
saisissions et que collectivement nous
apportions à ses contradictions une
réponse alors vous êtes près aussi
collectivement à porter cette réponse
mais moi je présente les grandes
réformes elles sont collectives la
réforme du master 2 dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure avec la sélection d'un certain
nombre de masters 2 elle a été préparée
par plus d'un an de concertation
nous sommes en train de préparer une
réforme très importante de l'entrée en
master 1 avec l'ensemble des partenaires
en l'ensemble des partenaires la
conférence des oiseaux l'enisa
bacheliers qui se voit freiné à l'entrée
de certaines filières avec 1
ils sont obligés d'aller étudier dans
des facs à l'étranger non c'est alors
d'abord ces chiffres il ya aucun chiffre
n'a aucun signal peut arriver comme en
3d projetée dans notre pays est nommé
avec des marrons très bien il n'y a
aucun chiffre qui atteste bien sûr il ya
des liens au cachet qui attestent qu on
parte à l'étranger pour nos enquêtes
tout simple c'est pour partir à
l'étranger voir payer donc et ça coûte
très cher de partir à l'étranger faire
ses études voilà et les perspectives de
démocratisation de l'enseignement super
de couches sociales que vous avez attiré
à lui attira universités n'ont pas les
moyens de partir à l'étranger en
revanche c'est pas vrai de dire qu'il
faut réserver les universités aux
meilleurs bacheliers ccc c'était sait
pour quelles raisons et pour quelles
raisons donc une part et par quel
raisonnement a bien fait mais moi mais
moi je pense qu'à l'université
on doit accueillir ceux qui ont les
profils qui leur permettront de réussir
pas seulement les 10% de meilleurs
bacheliers mais tous ceux qui ont les
profils pour réussir ça doit pas venir
axa doit pas devenir un club de
privilégiés l'université par définition
c'est le sens même du mot universités
c'est pas une grande école puisque vous
vous êtes fait une grande école
université c'est mieux qu'une grande
école ça qu'on s'y attendait mais les
notes un projet les notes un critère
important mais alors mai et celui qui
est 11e % de québec et le ok juste après
les 10% des meilleurs bacheliers
il n'a pas besoin d'aller à l'université
il a pas le navire la sorbonne mais on
parle on parle des bonnes excuses des
partenaires qui sont exclus on parle pas
de ce qui est tout le monde a droit d'y
aller bien sûr mais il ya des codes que
les bons élèves ne peuvent pas y accéder
mais versés rien s'ils ne tiennent pas
d'abord il faut voir avec le monde
il faut voir les demandes la réalité
c'est qu'il ya très peu de cas de bon
élève qui soit refuser une université
dans votre vie ailleurs il ya très peu
de vie à ce qu'on est en train de faire
c'est de faire en sorte que de toute
façon bon ou moyennes élèves on puisse
aller à l'université
les présidents d'université sont de
colère aussi le projet d'arrêté qui
permet à cinq universités d'expérimenter
le contrôle intégral
awesome c'était la fin des rattrapages a
été suspendu certains des pop up c'est
pas la fin des rattrapages
c'est pas rien cette affaire c'est la
fin de la session
dans la trappe âge c'est de la session
de septembre évasion arrière je n'en
reviens pas en arrière
ce qu'il dit on à un âge oui mais
j'explique devant devant vous on a un
agenda des réformes
on a fait le doctorat on a fait le
master 2 maintenant moi ce que je veux
réussir lundi sera avant la fin du
quinquennat
c'est le master 1 c'est la discussion
autour du cycle master pour revoir
repenser ce cycle là et ça c'est plus
importante où il faut qu'ils aient tous
les partenaires sociaux donc ça divise
le contrôle continu intégral les
syndicats étudiants sont pas d'accord
entre eux je vais pas les mettre le
bazar entre eux au moment où j'ai besoin
qu'on travaille ce cd à l'unef des
styles jeune mais ça c'est non mais ça
c'est de la présentation c'est des
histoires moi je veux pas être pris au
milieu des balles que ça change des
organisations de présidents d'université
et l organisation syndicale car autres
ou que ce que mais moi j'ai pas fait un
retour en arrière ce que je vous
explique
c'est lors la réforme du cycle master ça
doit passer avant tout et donc je
propose qu'on n'a plus peu de temps je
peux pas dans votre émission je parle
peut-être dans votre émigrés c'est
justement où se concentrent sur ça pour
réussir ses dernières grandes réformes
aient pu ensuite eh ben les suivants
peut-être nous ce que j'espère prendront
le contrôle continu intègre deux petites
questions autour du bac on a eu deux
chiffres ce soir des résultats 79 6 % de
réussite succès pour ce premier jour
en attendant les rattrapages j'ai
l'impression que ça ça c'est un chiffre
cohérent avec l'habitude en tout cas
aucune polémique notamment et internet
les oraux de rattrapage du bac tombe en
pleine fin du ramadan autour d'une fête
évidemment qu'il le célèbre
l'administration a proposé de reporter
au lendemain ces examens
est ce normal
donc je suis pas très informé de cet
élément le matin à cholet et considère
que c'est une désorganisation du bac
pour des raisons religieuses
voulez vous que c'est pas où c'est dans
quelle académie c'est partout c'est quoi
ile de france ile de france
faute d'information pardon non mais
alors par agir sans savoir à mot sur la
recherche donc on se souvient péter k
les critiques de certains au bal des
nobel français écouter jean jouzel qui
avait reçu on s'en souvient a vu avec le
giec
le nobel de la paix qui avait lancé cet
appel dans le monde il ya quelques
semaines sur la baisse des crédits il
semblait que le disons une des annonces
de françois hollande a été préservée du
budget de la recherche a été fait
préserver mais préservé du peut-être pas
suffisant et en tout cas c'est sale
avait été jusqu'en 2016 et nous étions
vraiment sur une pente descendante en
terme de budget c'est ce sur quoi nous
avons protesté collectivement avec donc
ses collègues en particulier dans une
tribu de la recherche mais il ya aussi
d'autres protestations par rapport aux
coupes qui était prévu et dont j'espère
qu'elles ont vraiment été annulé puisque
thierry mandon et là je m'adresse à
thierry mandon évidemment pour je suis
confiant qu'il maintiendra cette
vigilance par rapport au budget de la
recherche c'est surtout ce que nous
avons déjà discuté que nous ayons un
budget de la recherche 2017 qui soit
assez offensif c'est ça qui est très
important pour nous alors je confirme
monsieur jouzel à nos prix nobel un que
les crédits qui avait été un moment
convoité par des budgétaire qui cherche
toujours des sous c'est c'est comme ça
ont bien été finalement conservée
intégralement et deuxièmement je
confirme un monsieur je vous avais
accessoirement avoue même que il y aura
un effort budgétaire pour la recharge au
budget 2010 7,7 ailleurs à c'est à dire
vous allez savoir dans les jours qui
viennent puisque les arbitrages sont un
effet il y aura un effort budgétaire
pour la recherche le président la
république s'y est engagé il y aura un
effort budgétaire sur la recherche de
manière générale sur les organismes
parce qu'ils ont des charges nouvelles
qu'il faut en partie en tout cas
financer et sur le budget de l'agencé
nationale de la recherche le montant
voté
ben c'est ce que je suis
efforts budget augmenter bah ça vous
avez configuré dans les prochains dans
les prochains jours j'ai pas envie
d'avoir un tweet de monsieur eckert aaa
si je vais plus loin que les arbitrages
qui ne sont pas encore tout à fait rendu
à merci et au revoir merci merci à tous
bon soir la semaine prochaine c'est
bruno le maire qui sera l'invité de
trois par trois a très vite